(bluesy music)
(birds calling)
(fabric flapping)
(suspenseful music)
(motor humming)
(dramatic music)
(glass shattering)
(tires grinding on gravel)
(door slamming open)
(gagging)
(shouting)
Shit.
(distant sirens blaring)
Oh God.
(muttering)
Ah, ah sh...
(liquid dripping)
(sniffing)
Hoo-ah.
(coughing)
(sirens nearing)
Oh!
Okay.
Come on, come one, come on.
(camera dinging)
My name is Walter Hartwell White.
I live at 308 Negro Arroyo Lane,
Albuquerque, New Mexico 87104.
To all law enforcement entities,
this is not an admission of guilt.
I am speaking to my family now.
(sobbing)
Skyler, you are the love of my life.
I hope you know that.
Walter Junior, you're my big man.
There are...
There are going to be some things
that you'll come to learn about me
in the next few days.
I just want you to know
that no matter how it may look
I only had you in my heart.
Good-bye.
(sirens approaching)
(suspenseful music)
(heavy breathing)
(key clinking)
(door slamming)
(engine revving up)
(tires squealing)
(engine revving)
(metal clinking)
(laughing)
(shouting)
(labored breathing)
(coughing)
(tapping)
(sirens blaring)
(upbeat rock music)
♪ Guess I got what I deserved ♪
♪ Kept you waiting there
too long, my love ♪
♪ All that time without a word ♪
♪ Didn't know you'd
think that I'd forget ♪
♪ Or I'd regret ♪
♪ The special love I had for you ♪
♪ My baby blue ♪
♪ All the days became so long ♪
♪ Did you really think I'd do you wrong ♪
♪ Dixie when I let you go ♪
♪ Thought you'd realize
that I would know ♪
♪ I would show ♪
♪ The special love I have for you ♪
♪ My baby blue ♪